Here was the expression we agreed upon for the last two books of stamps. I'm
going to show you two ways of doing this and then we're going to figure out
which way is correct based on our diagram. For this first one, I'm going to
start in the parentheses. I know I need to simplify containers first. When I
look at this two, I can choose between the exponent or I can choose
multiplication. I'm going to choose the exponent first, so I'll get 2 times 5
times 4. I know 2 squared is 4. Right here, I have multiplication. Remember that
whenever you have a number outside of a parentheses, we just have multiplication
in front. 5 times 4 is 20 and I finish simplifying my parenthesis. Now, I can do
2 times 20, which is 40. This time for this second one, I'm still going to start
in parentheses, but for this two, I'm going to choose the, the multiplication
over the exponent. So I'm going to do 5 times 2 first, so I have 2 times 10
squared. I know 10 squared is 100, so I have 2 times 100 and I get 200. Okay.
One of these answers is correct. I know that in one book of stamps, I have 20
stamps, so in two books, I must have 40 stamps.
So here are two books of stamps and I can see that I should have 40 stamps
altogether. So I know that this method was correct. So, let's go back and look.
Here is where I made the choice. The two could have been paired with
multiplication or with exponents. I know that the two should be paired with the
exponent. The exponent takes priority over multiplication.
So with our order of operations, we know that we need to add in another
priority. Okay,. So when faced with the decision between an exponent and
multiplication, I know that the exponent or the power should come first. So
powers take the highest priority in our order of operations. When doing my order
of operations, I know power should come first, multiplication and division
should come second, and then addition and subtraction should come third. So you
might be wondering where parentheses fit on our order of operations. Well, we
just need to make sure we do the order of operations within each parentheses. We
need to simplify any parentheses or brackets before we do any outside operations
on them.